I'm gonna be playing a warlock I'll be
able playing a storm caller and I don't
know what time at stone caller plus I'm
gonna pass a clue help you know here
subject matter expert and explain oh
yeah of course speed of course be here a
little bit so yeah so the storm caller
is all about channeling lightning
through his hands and emperor
palpitating everybody so like shocking
guys down so for his set you'll see a
lot of the damage we visit revisited
here so pulse grenade and then Stormgren
a Disney grenade and that basically is
like a pocket storm you can just point
wherever you want you'll throw a grenade
and call down a storm super powerful
really fun to ease so he's got glide no
blank here but he's got blank and his
super removalist check that out in a
second kosmos go the focus burst here so
he wants a little initial boost of speed
storm trance like a sub call down
lightning from your hands and wrecked
guys that way cause I'm running what my
favorite ma here which is landfall which
is basically a way for you to float
above your enemies cast down a super
powerful lightning bolt and just blastic
a bunch of guys before you go into your
storm caller like storm trans stuff a
bunch of other tools here so double down
on the chaining capabilities or blink so
this is a good mobility option for
visualizing he had but he had to put it
in their summer did ya everybody loves
bling Thunder strike just a quick charge
Malik thing here and like this is
basically his his reign he has a high
range with this so it's basically the
way for him the shot guys but far before
finishing them off bunch of cool tools
here to enhance that pulse wave and
they're the cool team tool here when you
take damage a bunch of your allies will
but get a bunch of speed boost so you
can kind of avoid further damage easily
so you set that up so you can get a
speed booster exactly yeah so we can all
hop works I see you actually get their
feedback good way to kind of to take the
damage back to your here opponents
transcendence really good way to play
with energy building here perpetual
charge this is a good way for you to
play with like what you want to play
what your stats focus is going to be
here we'll how
going to recharge your energy our clubs
that are a great way to focus on your
damage chaining capabilities an
electrostatic mind is another good way
to build your super faster so this is
actually charges your super faster when
you're near allies so this thing's
really well with pulse wave so i'll be
sure to run away from you so i gotta
stay close I have to get all the kids
though there you go enough for your
artifact I have the heliopause bond
we're down oh that's not bad I have the
tissue in the Bengal I'm gonna see that
may have a chance to generate an orb
when killing a minion of darkness so
that'll be great leave fantastic all
right our fire team is configured and
ready for battle so go ahead we've set
destination